in my name is polo social I am the dj
of ignite
I am an acrobat too who worked
to make light cheese but now I am
returning to my career as a dj with
music now
or here
I hope the stick
is of the essence
the show since  we are all
artists who were working to
follow their law and for other companies on
the street we all got together we
started with this idea of ​​starting something
so that the artists have something to
do for the public also that is not going
to be live entertainment
therefore  We were already working here for a while
the show is great we do the
performances freely
and there it is
[Music]
I know where it is
yes yes yes yes sure we have
difficulties also with the sound of the
music of the power of everything but it is a
challenge that we are that  we are
ready for as it is said
as it is said we are ready for what
we do so that we go strong that
we remain strong that we can make a
show  ass for everyone
only good things yes we are all the work
the artists with the music we have I
am the dj but I have three musicians
working next year we have
only one power that was on
madonna's tour we have
the drama that was in close to
humanistic suns we also have a
singer who was in secret alone and
zumanity of all return to the arts
I can assure you that it will be a good
show because they are all very strong